die mondlandung am 20 juli 1967 auch
heute wohl immer noch einer der größten
momente der menschheitsgeschichte der
man on the moon und millionen von
menschen haben mitgefiebert und der reiz
ist nicht kleiner geworden wir berichten
hier immer wieder über pläne demnächst
mal wieder auf dem mond zu landen doch
wie ist die mondlandung damals wirklich
abgelaufen was ist von den
verschwörungstheorien zu halten nachdem
die mondlandung niemals stattgefunden
hat ihr habt euch dieses thema bei
whatsapp und den anderen messen
gewünschten bekommt jetzt die fünf
spannendsten facts der mondlandung
herzlich willkommen bei klick zum
science fiction
vorab noch etwas zu den messengern die
abo boxee auf youtube.de ist ja schlimm
ihr habt einfach keine möglichkeit
sicherzustellen dass sie eher fad wenn
ein neues video online geht deshalb
meine bitte in meinem vor allem aber
auch in eurem interesse folgten mehr auf
whatsapp und den anderen messengern nur
dann verpasst ihr garantiert kein video
mehr
und jetzt könnt ihr euch übrigens da
auch über einen disco server miteinander
verknüpfen
auf der 5 darum sind keine sterne auf
den bildern der mondlandung zu sehen war
die mondlandung echt oder war alles nur
inszeniert ihr wisst wahrscheinlich alle
dass sich um kaum ein thema mehr
verschwörungstheorien ranken als um die
mondlandung von 1969 demnach ist die
apollo-11-mission nie dort oben auf dem
mond gewesen stattdessen hat die nasa
alles in einem großen filmstudio
inszeniert einer der beweise dafür auf
den bildern der mondlandung sind keine
sterne zu sehen
ja zudem weht die amerikanische flagge
dabei gibt es doch gar kein wind auf dem
mond und doch wahrscheinlich ja alles
schon für dieses angebliche für diese
angeblichen beweise gibt es
wissenschaftliche erklärungen auf den
aufnahmen sind zum beispiel keine sterne
zu sehen weil die sonneneinstrahlung die
mondoberfläche und die astronauten sehr
hell erscheinen lässt die sterne
leuchten dagegen nur schwach damit aber
die astronauten auf dem bild auftauchen
ist eine sehr kurze belichtungszeit
nötig mit der sich das leuchten der
sterne nicht mehr einfangen lässt auch
auf den meisten anderen fotos aus dem
all sind die sterne ja meistens aus
diesem grund nicht zu sehen und hier auf
der erde sind ja übrigens tagsüber auch
keine sterne zu sehen es ist einfach zu
helfen und auch das wesen der flagge hat
einen grund natürlich gleich die montur
atmosphäre einem vakuum dort oben geht
kein einziges münchen
doch die flagge wird von neil armstrong
in den boden gerammt und durch diese
erschütterung bewegt sich die flagge
dort oben
das hört aber nach einiger zeit auf und
die flagge bleibt still auf der vier
armstrongs fußabdruck auf dem mond
bleibt wohl ewig der fußabdruck von neil
armstrong ist wohl das symbol
schlechthin für die erste mondlandung
zitat nur ein kleiner schritt für einen
menschen aber ein großer sprung für die
menschheit das hat er gesagt auf
englisch als er auf der ersten sprosse
der leiter stand um aus dem lande modul
namens igel als erster mensch auf die
mondoberfläche hinabzusteigen den
armstrong ist längst tot doch seit
fußabdruck wohl
für die ewigkeit auf dem mond denn dort
gibt es wie gesagt kein wind durch den
er verwehrt werden könnte es gibt kein
wetter keine witterung nichts was den
fußabdruck auslöschen könnte höchstens
einen asteroiden oder meteoriten
anschlag könnte den abdruck zerstört auf
der 3 die mondlandung war wirklich ein
absolut riesiges medienspektakel
die drei astronauten an bord der
raumfähre columbia wurden durch ihre
reise zum mond zu weltweiten stars
monatelang hatte ihr training für die
reise ins all gedauert noch in den drei
tagen der reise selbst hatten sie kaum
etwas zu tun
auf den rund 380.000 kilometern zum mond
hatten sie hauptsächlich fernseh
interviews zu geben der auf der erde
verfolgte wohl die gesamte menschheit
das schicksal von neil armstrong michael
collins und edwin aldrin
das waren wirklich krasse einsatz wurden
damals denn soviel fernsehgeräte gab es
noch nicht rund 600 millionen menschen
oder aushalte verfolgten jedes detail am
fernseher als sie drei helden wieder
sicher auf der erde gelandet waren
mussten sie zunächst übrigens drei
wochen in quarantäne um keine
krankheiten vom mond einzuschleppen man
wusste ja nicht ob und was dort oben
hätte sein können um gehen lieber auf
nummer sicher danach wurden sie bei
einer großen parade in new york gefeiert
auf der 2 ein wirkliches fun fact zurück
wie müll und andere umweltsünden nach 22
stunden aufenthalt verließ die igel
wieder den mond doch die untere hälfte
der startrampe ließ das team zurück an
ihr befestigt eine plakette mit dem
schriftzug hier setzten menschen vom
planeten erde im juli 1969 anno domini
ihren fuß auf den mond wir kamen in
frieden für die menschheit
unterschrieben hatten dass der
amerikanische präsident richard nixon
und die drei astronauten aber das war
nicht das einzige was das team als
andenken auf dem mond zurück ließ auch
ihre moonboots lehre essenspakete und
volle urinbeutel ließen sie zurück das
gewicht hätte gegebenenfalls den start
der igel gefährden können und auf der
einst die nasa waren vor zunehmendem
verkehr auf dem mond das ist wirklich
verrückt es gibt immer mehr pläne schon
zeitnah wieder auf dem mond zu landen
unter anderem ja auch von ihnen maske
und genau das macht der nasa sorgen und
so hat die us raumfahrtbehörde eine art
verhaltens regelwerk aufgestellt und
zwar nicht dass etwas passieren könnte
befürchten sie sondern nasa geht es um
die bodendenkmalpflege
ja hier auf der erde sind dafür
archäologen zuständig der werden dörfer
von menschen ausgegraben römische villen
und relikte aus urzeiten sowas auf dem
mond ja auf 93 seiten geht es darum wie
man apollo relikte und landesstellen auf
dem mond schützen kann
denn durch die vielen raumschiffe die in
den nächsten jahren zum mond reisen
wollen könnten die messinstrumente rover
landeplätze und fahnen leiten das ganze
soll also für die nachwelt erhalten
bleiben
zudem fordert die nasa auch auf den mond
als naturpark oder historische stätte zu
schützen
gut dass es kein unesco ehrt kultur erbe
gibt sondern das weltkulturerbe
da könnten dann auch die apollo
landeplätze auf dem mond so benannt
werden ja wenn ihr kein video zu den
neuen plänen zur besiedlung des mondes
und zu allen anderen themen verpassen
wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp und
den anderen messengern nur dann verpasst
er kein video denn die abo box auf
youtube ist ja immer ziemlich lückenhaft
über die messenger erfahrt ihr von mir
auch vor allen anderen vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
hier abonnieren
da erfahrt ihr das neueste aus der
social media welt aber nicht die genau
glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter dafür auch drauf
dicken menschen sollen auf dem mond
siedeln bis dann bleibt dran